bathed in light adorned with
color every piece linked to the life of
a Ukrainian Soldier a life saved by an
armored plate when you're looking at
this it's it's so much more than than
art than absolutely this is uh it
transcends art it's much more deeper
than art but to feel that uh emotional
connection you probably have to have the
experience of feeling the war
firstand battling against a fullscale
Russian invasion for nearly 2
years has left its mark on every aspect
of life in Ukraine families torn apart
homes destroyed lives and
bodies forever changed all what we do
it's a contribution of of the defense of
Ukraine speak with Genny sevuk says his
favorite pieces are from Ukrainian
children their work like the rest
reflects their culture their
personalities and the realities of War
art armor was launched in 2022
originally with works by famous local
artists as a fundraiser for the
Ukrainian armed forces the terrifying
marks of those bullets and
shrapnel as you can see very visibly on
all of these plates tell the story of
the ongoing war in Ukraine better than
any words possibly could some of the
pieces will eventually be auctioned off
with proceeds going towards more
protective gear Rehabilitation efforts
and Dem mining projects Canada house in
London is the last stop of the
exhibition's European tour but it's not
the end organizers are looking for
artists anywhere in the world with an
eye for creating Beauty from
brutality Crystal ganing Global News
London